- Top reasons why I love being black.
Oh my god, you see this skin?
- There is so much richness and history
behind my skin.
- I just love the soul, like I don't know
how to describe it other than that.
- Do you see this skin?
- We're not just one part of the box.
We encompass everything.
- This is what I think about black culture
I think about how powerful
it is, I think about the fact
that our ancestors are the ones that you
could not break.
- If I woke up, and I was
anything other than black,
I would be completely jealous.
- Black twitter is lit, you know.
- My melanin pop, that's
why this outfit works,
you don't see nobody
else rocking a baby blue
outfit out here like this.
- Black loves. Whenever we come together
and we, know what I'm saying, this is like
nothing else.
- Before I came to America,
being black was the
only thing I knew. For
me, it's my identity.
Nobody can take this away from me.
- Black just doesn't have one definition.
My black is different from her black.
- I can come to a place
like this and just see
so much beauty and diversity, see so many
people who are just like
proud of their melanin.
And like, dancing to our own music.
- The originality and the strength.
Never duplicated, always imitated.
But just the strength and
the creativity that we have
in our culture.
- We're loud and we're proud of it.
And the culture is so fricking rich.
- And it's like, wherever
you go in the world,
is a kind of unity. Like,
everyone knows the nod.
- I just love all of our
features. Like there's
nothing like it. The
sun can't even break us.
- We just created this
whole culture that's like,
it's influencing the entire world now.
- As it says on my poster here,
I am dipped in chocolate,
bronzed in elegance,
enabled with grace, and
I am toasted with beauty.
That is why I love being black.
- [Voiceover] I think that
it's amazing to come from
a people who have overcome,
and who strive to be great,
people who are great.
- Black excellence, shout out
to all the recent graduates.
- We always are given
scraps, like chitlins,
the bottoms of the bottom,
and we take those things,
and we make them into cultural staples.
- Collectively, we're
one, but individually,
we're beautiful.
- Some black people, you can't
pinpoint back where exactly
you came from, but you can feel it.
- We're not confined to
one thing. I learned from
different people, different cultures,
and we're all brought together
by the color of our skin.
- Black women can wear any color
of the rainbow and look amazing.
- Amongst like the discrimination,
and the racial tension
in our country, I'd still
wouldn't rather be anything else.
- We are like a community
of beauty and resiliency.
- In all honesty, we're just poppin'.
- Black Christians, black lives matter!
- I love it! Like honestly,
there's so many things.
- Come on now, look at our
fashion. Look at our rules.
Look at where we come from.
Why wouldn't you want to be black?